welcome to the American
Society of magical
[Music]
Negroes I know you can feel their
discomfort
Aaron watching you walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I don't want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in it
welcome to the American
Society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand it's
easier to
show what's the most dangerous animal on
the planet sharks white people when they
feel uncomfortable white people feeling
uncomfortable precedes a lot of bad
stuff for us that's why we fight white
discomfort every day because the happier
they are the safer we are the name these
a little updating maybe like
magical black people or I guess that
doesn't have the same
ring you ready oh wow your first client
is a Jason M his morale is far too low
hey hey darn it I was hoping there was a
station right next to him oh is this one
spoken for no yeah it's actually fun and
weirdly relaxing it's like being a
secret agent with none of the danger hey
I'm luy nice to meet you nice to meet
you she's great yeah she's cool you
kidding come on man she's smart and
funny I know what you were doing going
on about her you're trying to set us up
no no no that's not what I was doing you
cannot have a relationship with Liz now
because if you don't put Jason first
everyone's magic will
fail I've always felt like it's my job
to make white people feel comfortable
and here it literally
is but maybe it shouldn't be I got a
great plan to ask her out but I'm going
to need your help do you think you can
like work your magic hey is you talking
about me hey oh my wait are you you but
I TR a long
way someone toi the society who was it
you didn't let her go like I told you if
you interfere with her or your client
you could have your memory erased you
won't even remember she
existed even though we might never see
each other again I need you to know that
what we had was
real I'm curious to see how you going to
make it out of all
[Music]
this
I